bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors le rôle de l'urss
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale at il
été à minimiser
je crois que ça fait parti d'un contexte
historique d'une part la guerre froide
ne l'oublions pas il faut aussi se
rappeler que les temps changent et
aujourd'hui que on peut peut-être parler
de l'histoire passée avec moins de
polémique même si elles reviennent on en
sait plus et puis je crois aussi que
cette deuxième guerre mondiale ne
l'oublions pas c'était entre l'union
soviétique et l'allemagne une lutte à
mort nations étaient concernés et puis
aujourd'hui c'était pas la même
situation donc on peut comprendre
aujourd'hui que la réussie et non pas
l'une aux soviétiques réhabilite ce rôle
majeur au monde toile de reconnaître
dans la règlement de ce conflit ça sans
aucun doute
alors pas de président français ni même
de mini seul l'ambassadeur français de
russie étaient présents à ce défilé sur
la place rouge bâton il voir quelque
chose peut-on interpréter je n'ai pas
d'interprétation au sens politique du
terme personnellement ayant lu quand
même que le président macron devaient
être présents le 9 mai dernier
il peut être surprenant que cette fois
ci ne soit pas là maintenant notre nos
problèmes de politique intérieure
aujourd'hui sont tellement important
qu'on peut expliquer cette absence par
ce fait car il n'y a pas eu de
divergences avec la russie depuis
plusieurs semaines ya pas eu de
polémique majeur donc je penserai et je
pencherais plutôt pour une situation de
d'opportunités le présent appel n'était
pas disponible je ne crois pas qu'il
faut y voir un signe politique fort
même si on peut constater qu'il n'y a
pas d'autre dirigeant important du monde
occidental alors sur le plan stratégique
un même militaire quelle relation moscou
entretient avec paris par exemple en ce
moment même en ce moment même on reçoit
des stagiaires par exemple à l'école de
guerre
même s'ils ne sont pas nombreux mais il
ya des échanges jeu mais je n'en connais
pas beaucoup actuellement je ne sais
simplement que les rapports avec les
états majors et une réunion d'état major
et quelques mois entre l'état major
français l'état major russe
cela se passe
bien et reconnaissons quand même que les
relations entre la russie et la france
du point de vue militaire ont toujours
été bonnes
je crois qu'on a des relations anciennes
même parfois si on s'est battu mais la
réalité est que nous nous estimons
mutuellement et c'est une ça c'est une
réalité
maintenant après c'est la politique donc
dissocions bien les relations politiques
des relations militaires en termes de
relations militaires
nous estimons nous comprenons mais après
nous sommes soumis aux orientations
politiques bien sûr alors treize mille
militaires 1 230 véhicules de combat 75
avions hélicoptères ont participé tout à
l'heure ce matin ce défilé il ya même eu
plusieurs nouveautés cette année
comment se porte l'armée russe j'ai
beaucoup apprécié ce défilé je dis
honnêtement il avait de la lure d'abord
j'ai été frappé par la jeunesse des
soldats qui défilaient et puis aussi par
j'irai l'horaire bar sial qu'il faut
vous admire pour un militaire c'est
normal néanmoins je trouve que ce défilé
avait beaucoup d'alluré avec une jeune
armée russe avec des soldats qui avaient
l'air fier de ce qu'ils avaient ça c'est
l'aspect humain maintenant l'aspect je
dirais technique voyons bien qu'il ya du
matériel hautement performants qu'à des
filets en termes de chars notamment qui
suit tankiste d'origine
j'avoue que j'ai vu du matériel assez
impressionnant et même réellement
impressionnant on a vu aussi quand même
ce qu'on n'avait pas évoqué il ya
quelques instants ces missiles
intercontinentaux qui sont quand même un
élément important de la stratégie de
dissuasion nucléaire de la russie
faire défiler des missiles mobiles à
portée importante
ap en transportant des charges
nucléaires c'est aussi un signe alors
n'oublions pas qu'à défilé militaire
ce n'est pas uniquement avoir de belles
images c'est aussi un message qu'on veut
faire passer et moi ce que j'ai vu ce
matin c'est une force russe fonctionnel
bien équipé fière de ce qu'elle de ce
qu'elle est et de ce qu'elle a fait et
c'est le message je pense que vladimir
poutine voulait porter à la face du
monde
aucun message qui a bien été passé selon
vous on verra pour les experts et les
politiques ces deux mondes différents
techniquement sans aucun doute
politiquement c'est un autre sujet mais
je pense que si on reprend ce qui s'est
passé depuis plusieurs années
je dirais depuis 2011 2012 et la syrie
en particulier dont on en a peu parlé ce
matin par allusion c'est quand même le
retour sur la scène de la puissance
militaire de la russie
c'est une réalité est aujourd'hui valait
d'ymir poutine ne pouvait pas ne pas le
rappeler un certain nombre d'états
occidentaux qui aurait eu une tendance
pendant pas mal d'années à se désarmer
aujourd'hui la réalité est la puissance
militaire fait partie des outils du
politique pour faire valoir ses intérêts
et défendent bien sûr son pays françois
souvent c'est merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct vous rappelle que vous
êtes général de brigade expert en géo
stratégie merci d'avoir été en direct
avec nous